it has just gone dark when the skies
above gomer turned an ominous color
mount near a gongo began erupting around
7pm
sending a river of molten lava down at
steep slopes
it quickly engulfed roads and sent panic
residents running for safety
many fled east towards the border with
rwanda
others didn't know where to go
we've come from the village fleeing the
fire from the volcano's lava
we looked into the sky and we saw the
red color from the volcano we are
looking for a place to shelter
we don't know what to do we don't even
know how to act there's no information
even on the national channel people are
panicking
and we don't know if we should stay in
the house or flee
initially scientists said the lava flow
was heading away from gomer
but now they're warning that new
fractures are putting 2 million
residents at risk seismic activity could
probably means that some other fractures
are opening
or even simply that is the
activity itself because it's the rift
that is moving it's not the volcano
itself the volcano open
because the reef is moving i think the
civil defense is already evacuating all
the people
they were already signed that most of
the people were going
through sarcas on the western side of
the volcano
the volcano lies at the albertine rift
and has been an ongoing threat to locals
for decades
the last eruption in 2002 cut a path
through gomer's business district
and flowed into lake kivu this
along with choking fumes earthquakes and
collapsed buildings
killed around 240 people
a huge lava lake has remained since
now the risk from the eruption poses an
immediate danger
for people living below the flow of
molten rock is expanding
and remains unpredictable law about
manly al jazeera